It's so hot.
Did we wander
into the Amazon jungle or something?
Don't make me laugh.
Compared to the hell
of 122-degree heat during the race,
this jungle is a fake.
That's right.
This shouldn't exist in this world.
We must destroy it.
Could they be…
Uranus Crystal Power!
Neptune Crystal Power!
Pluto Crystal Power!
Saturn Crystal Power!
Make Up!
The protector
of the Planet of the Sky, Uranus,
Guardian of Flight!
Sailor Uranus!
The protector of the Planet of the Deep
Sea, Neptune, Guardian of Embrace!
Sailor Neptune!
Protector of the Planet of Space-Time,
Pluto, Guardian of Revolution!
Sailor Pluto!
Protector of the Planet of Silence,
Saturn, Guardian of Ruin and Birth!
Sailor Saturn!
We have arrived!